[Musique]
voir les enfants
vous avez l'air étonné oui je suis seul
et je cherche nos sources ce qu'aucun
est parti sans me dire où ils allaient
je vais téléphoner à nicolas et
pimprenelle
peut-être ont-ils de ses nouvelles
allô allô c'est pas preneur oui c'est
pas très bien et nicolas bonsoir les
enfants est-ce que nounours et chez vous
nous l'attendons si vous le voyez dites
lui que moi aussi je l'attends oui
d'accord petit marchand de sable on lui
dira s'il me lui gier j'ai dit gilles
ragot volé des étagères
les étagères
tout simple un
outil dit que j'ai beau m'être los ninos
de la messieurs ccq donc nous n'avons
pas besoin de tes chers mais s'ils
prenaient
faudrait bien vous mettent d'accord dans
ce que moi je commence à faire trop et
salle où monsieur fautrel
je suis menuisier
monsieur menusier poser vos planches moi
et toi
[Musique]
mais sur ses étagères on pourra mettre
tous les livres d histoire que maman
sera pas celle des vous revient
ne tirez pas sur mais bouge ta
[Applaudissements]
petit rôle ils m'ont reconnu mais je
vous ai quand même bien notre appui
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
moi j'ai planté des clous avec un
marteau piège de louvain pr même aux non
pas ce soir nicolas il est trop tard
pour travailler bon ben là tiens je te
laisse ma casquette et mon foulard de
menuisier merci non
sa fille comprendre rien va vite te
coucher nicolas je t'accompagne
vaut mieux banon c'est en patron à temps
il nous a téléphoné il là je me sauve de
nuit le zoo mot
[Musique]
bonne nuit et merci menuisier
tiens te revoilà je fais une bonne farce
à mes amis patrons ils ont failli ne pas
me reconnaître
ce te drôle tu repars avec moi ou
est bien en route bonne nuit des enfants
faute de pur
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]